we are all devastated by the news that  we have just heard from Balmoral  the death of her majesty the queen is a  huge shock to the nation and to the  world  Queen Elizabeth II was the rock on which  modern Britain was built  our country has grown and flourished  under her reign  Britain is the great country it is today  because of her  she ascended the throne just after the  second World War  she championed the development of the  Commonwealth from a small group of seven  countries to a family of 56 Nations  spanning every continent of the world  we are now a modern thriving Dynamic  Nation  through second thing  Queen Elizabeth II provided us with the  stability and the strength that we  needed  she was the very Spirit of Great Britain